und damit herzlich zu einer runde etwas
zusammen
jeder kriegt ein ok und letzten teil
okay das machen wir bestimmt fünfzehn
einzige rausfliegen für mich sind
normalerweise gegner hieß das ist eine
wasch bundes das heißt für uns
eigentlich rekord aufstellen mal viele
sagen also kannst du mir irgendwie chef
mitbringen was brauchst du denn wie zu
lange gekauft gerade nur irgendwas war
ich schon dreimal verklebt
entschuldigung weil die bahn sich nicht
in die mitte alle asus darüber gegangen
ist natürlich redet was du machst du
gerade oder wie habe ich die reise
dankeschön dann kauf dir auch in bogen
und dann aber leider bauen die sich
nicht die mittel sonst hat man ja ich
schon mit meinem eines grünen
ich gehe jetzt erstmal zu grün sein kann
ich mir okay wünsche ich dir dabei schon
mal viel spaß würde ich hier vorstellen
temporäre tatsächlich an spannend werden
du schaffst das sturm waffe du bist die
beste sturm war für die ich kenne
danke schön und ich lange vermisst weil
irgendwie bin ich
nicht aber eine gestorben so rich sagen
können ja würde ich auch sagen
gegen die große frage wer geld mehr ich
habe jetzt habt ihr ganz viel zeug
gelegt was warum wir sind wir sind
gerade feinde auch wenn wir gleich team
sind uns gucken wer mehr geld ich habe
schon ein team aber wirst du dich
betrogen
danke nicht gerade umdrehen und
innovativ dass dieses wir sind auf dem
weg von abo wir darstellt liegt ein
fieses nicht okay okay den letzten wir
uns auch noch los geht's vielleicht
wieder schnell also ich hab keine blöcke
- ein bisschen das problem gerade ich
habe aber bisher haben wir gespielt das
kann uns keiner vor
wer bisher haben wir immer nur noch
immer allein ich immer wieder die base
40 parks
aber eigentlich was wirklich fair wir
hatten nicht so alleine zum thema also
ich hab den eingebogen abgeschlossen das
waren diese blöd aber letztendlich nicht
es wäre vielleicht knapp gewesen aber
ich hab mir eigentlich so ziemlich in
dem moment und leiter von dem was ich
mache jetzt hier irgend ein klima der
base dass mein ding jetzt macht das
mache und flug in der business überlebte
dieses er überlebt durch dieses wieso
konnte er dieses bloß überleben
exakt einer cranio nickel alter ist
richtig ist es laut pumpernickel mit
irgend kommt jetzt geht's richtig bhd
dass man uns beide weil wir so nur
allein erwischt das war eine knackige
runde eine kamera zieht sich die
schnelle runde die man dran hängt die
ganze england schnell der alltag schon
ein paar mal bekommen das war nur mit
luca mit du kannst ja weißt du noch als
das braucht einbauen
es war lustig auch die klassische 100
watt paletten drei pferde waren wir eine
lustige konstellationen
falls ich gekannt haben sollte was ich
nicht glaube hallo zu werden ich schon
immer auf die straße die leute sehen so
sagt es nicht so dass ich das bin okay
okay
nein unter geschlagen
das könnte es knapp werden ja das ist so
nicht oder erst ein paar minuten gerade
einmal noch vor allem von dem gerede vom
guten herrn richtiger kommst du durch
oder also nichts für den jungen
das wird beide getötet weißt du das
sagst das einfach so ist es ist nichts
für dich aber betclic sie nicht kessler
ist diese fakten youtube-channel
steampunk gemessen weil oder sowas oder
oder plastik oder wie wäre es mit
diesmal hatten wir keinen kein
anständiges match ja und ich bedient wir
haben schon anständiges match fit und
wird ich produziere gerade für morgen
vor und ich bin das nicht gewohnt videos
funktioniert dass sie gerade überlege
schon so her was man hier zu schnell als
thumbnail weil ich ja gleich erfolge
dran weiß gleich hoch bitte das mit den
erfolgen rande zu überlegen was für die
folgen imst nein eigentlich nicht
was muss nicht im team schreiben das
mögen die leute sie zeigte keine
kommentare
sie zeigt lang sie doch zeigt sie doch
das hatte ich nie was bei deinem es
anders nach dem 38 dass das ihr gutes
reihen und kommentare
aber gerade ein besiegter darf man redet
immer zu unserem sport sein alter ist
das ein richtiger romantischer süß kopf
ist ich bin recht hat diana die das
erzählte stimmt diana kommt sollte mir
jetzt erzählen wusste ich aber weiß das
denn die ideale sind über mich was habe
ich eigentlich nicht so viel über die
gleise als ob verdammt aber unser bett
noch da na ja ich habe aber gerade eben
1 zerstört jetzt ist da diese eine rolle
die hat es noch überlebt ich muss jetzt
sehen ob ich habe ich gerade getötet die
ganze zeit gegen den jungen chinesen
eine metapher ist nur mit passfoto
etappen
ich muss gerade sneak gewerken auf die
kleine schulkinder hinten okay bob was
sie denkt ich bin ft ft
aber glauben dass menschen dass man
einfach elf kam in der runde rumsteht er
nicht das funktioniert aber echt
meistens nur dass die leute dann denken
so jungen wahllos wie blaue hat da gar
nicht so bock drauf seiten du hast ein
schwert das 30 halt das ist großes
problem
haben sie verwechselt es hat geklappt
dieser firma afk trick der klassiker und
ich hab keine blöcke ich hab da kannst
du gelb gehe zwar schwer aber ich hab
mit schwert und bogen
ich hätte auch verantwortung
willst du mir ist ein bisschen
übertragen
hast du auch das geld verantwortung ist
auch übertragen
ich mache weiter kriegen wollen wir team
rot nef quatsch ich hab keine links noch
nach einer kompletten team blau erstmal
ja ja ja ich hab alles war nicht leicht
aber wir holen uns erstmal diesen typen
kommt schneller und habe gesagt ja dann
machen wir wenn er wirklich kommt dann
wird er seine mutter also der bau jetzt
fort
ich dachte vielleicht fallen
gehst du durch zu ihm ich mach das und
ich war einfach den game im auge behält
natürlich jetzt dick eingebaut da ist
gut sehr oben nicht das kannst du dir
nicht denken brauchen auf der map das
ist leider das problem muss ich
unbedingt als problem sehen wir sind
alle noch da haben wir drei runden in ca
ein bisschen mehr als zehn minuten
geschafft wäre schon alle haben ja und
was vom faktor ich schon wieder einen
kommentar zu dieser aus los bei euch
er hat mich gerettet nicht
wahrscheinlich weil die beste rüstung
hatte raffael kommt er kommt mit online
er darf hingegen ganz wird die runde
lang lang oder der contact studiert das
war natürlich auch spannend
okay ich gehe es geht zu ihm um die
weltverband uci hatte auch schon längst
nicht mehr
und ich hab so dumm gespielt ich hoffe
ich komme schnell sein veto gegen ein
bestimmtes gerade geschlechts kann oder
wie man sie ja schon bisher hatte ich
glaube nicht oder doch eher lustig in
jedem fall unterhaltsam besonders weil
ich keine voller rüstung an eine
leidvolle was sollte das jetzt so kann
man auch mal drüber reden
wenn man so was macht wie du jetzt ich
hab' gerät bestens dachte er würde noch
er würde noch ein blätter deshalb du
kannst den alten scart weggeschossen
keine volle wusste um dieses problem
sturm ig drauf aber wenn ich drauf
gericht gehe ich drauf neben haider
gesagt okay so und ich mach so epische
musik wenn du ich muss so langsam
du kannst aber nicht zu teleportieren
mit der report plattform da müsste
ungefähr sein deine chance endlich zu
machen ich möchte dass wir gewinnen
wir können nicht alle drei runden
klassiert in die mitte kommen können
werden die ersten beiden umgewandelt da
müssen wir jetzt ein ja auch gewinnen
ok vertreten und daher alles easy alles
easy x die altbewährte sich einfach an
wie er auf dem po krieg seht also bist
du in der mitte
denn du wirst jetzt gehe ich von mir
eine freude zu blocken geht das
eigentlich noch absagte schießt immer
fein raus meine blaue denn ich sehe mit
wie komm doch mal was in den kongo und
busy tourist.de ersten mal getroffen
dann war das 3 sterne runden in weniger
als mehr als 31